vous pensez qu'ils sont Amandine et
Alexandre vous pensez qu'ils sont ils
m'ont demandé de venir ce soir pour
faire la promo de leur renouveau film
bah oui bien sûr
c'était juste parce que parce qu'elle
voulait vous montrer qu'elle est voilà
juste vraiment pour pouvoir nous
exprimer euh
c'était ça ce nouveau projet film
Guillaume pas du tout tu crois pas trop
mais moi je reste sur mes positions je
pense que c'est pas un métier ce n'est
pas un métier ce que vous faites je
pense que vous avez été utilisé par une
plateforme qui surf sur votre buzz et
moi pardon mais j'en peux plus
d'entendre les mots business chef
d'entreprise commerce on dirait des
patrons du CAC 40 pardon mais vous dites
où vont des contenus digitaux à nos
abonnés pardon la chauve-source que vous
vendez c'est votre cul je suis désolé
mais c'est vrai ce n'est pas un travail
et ne pas aller pas le jour le jour
c'est de parler
mais arrêtez de faire croire que c'est
un travail
c'est des patrons du chat de 40 non
[Applaudissements]
c'est un métier je pense que vendre des
contenus j'ai regardé vos vidéos elle
coûte 3 €, je trouve pardon en fait ça
me fait de la peine pour vous poser
votre vidéo
unique sur la plateforme du du site qui
diffuse le film j'ai peur que vous ayez
dans une dans une escalade à nous et
nous croyons qu'on a pas été payé 3
euros d'une part parce qu'il y a eu un
ce soir à la plateforme est-ce que vous
l'avez dit ce soir vous inquiétez pas on
va faire TPMP ça va être bien pour les
vues jamais de la vie
ce n'était pas le premier motif non non
nous notre motivation pour revenir ce
soir c'est pour pour nous exprimer en
fait on se fait insulter juger comme on
l'a été pendant trois soirs d'affilée on
vous a jamais insulté
ce qu'on pense bah vous pouvez le faire
dans le respect comme là toujours là
c'est respectueux ce soir on est dans le
respect des règles le film c'est pas du
tout notre notre argumentaire pour venir
ce soir absolument pas au contraire je
voulais justement mettre en avant le
fait que le gouvernement cette année
allait mettre en place justement une une
comment dire une application non pas oui
une application en tout cas une
obligation de tous les sites
pornographiques en France
justifier de l'identité et de là
monsieur qui accède au Site et une
formation
comme ça ils sont pas du tout ils sont
déjà en tout cas ils ont déjà appliqué
ça depuis longtemps faut pas dire
n'importe quoi
c'est un métier c'est un vrai travail
voilà un métier voilà c'est quelque
chose de différent néanmoins je pense et
je reste professionnel donc sur ma même
ligne de ce qu'elle a dit de choix au
monde avec son métier dans les mains
arrêtez quoi éduquer des enfants c'est
aussi un métier et je pense qu'il faut
aussi avoir une responsabilité
maintenant qu'il soit heureux qui
kiffent leur vie et qui protège leurs
enfants prenez un maximum d'argent pour
protéger vos enfants pour plus tard
s'ils ont besoin de vous vous serez là
soyez heureux qui fait voilà moi je
reste sur une position je trouve que
c'est on veut tous faire des choses dans
la vie mais quand on a des enfants il
faut aussi assumer ses enfants et et
je peux dire un truc la dernière fois
Amandine elle m'a dit un truc à la fin
de l'émission elle m'a dit tout le monde
a dit que mon fils était génial et ben
c'est moi qui l'ai levé donc pourquoi
ils disent que j’élève mal les endroits
parce que tout le monde dit qu'il est
génial ici mais parce que une fois de
plus on n'a pas le le délinquant ça
serait de ma faut mais dans le respect
on n'a pas le retour aujourd'hui c'est
facile de dire nos enfants ne verront
pas nos vidéos ils ont trois ans ils ont
6 ans ils ont 6 ans on est dans le
respect ou pas donc c'est facile
aujourd'hui de dire innoverront pas les
vidéos tu ne peux pas savoir si les
verrons ou pas donc moi je pars de ce
principe là je me dis que moi aussi je
voulais aussi faire des choses mais j'ai
deux enfants et j'ai préféré assumer mes
deux enfants et je suis pas parti dans
n'importe quel délire de faire tout et
n'importe quoi je pense que se lancer
c'est mon choix perso je ne juge pas
soyez heureux mais se lancer dans le X
avec 8 enfants comme ça
se lancer une fois
je pense que c'est ne pas penser à eux
et je peux me tromper je suis pas
psychologique psychiatre je peux me
tromper maintenant soyez heureux faites
votre vie Amandine j'habite plein de
bonheur